polémique de la semaine les stars qui
sont clinique est critiqué pour tout et
n'importe quoi
les critiques peuvent s'avérer justifié
parfois d'autres occasions c'est
aberrant souvent de ribéry qui mangent
entre eux au nord on montre une voiture
de sports ou n'importe quoi ça devient
hallucinant qu'est ce que vous en pensez
regardez je viens les dunes ma petite
théorie ou jeudi il ya les homos et les
gays pierre palmade distincts église au
mode higuain et di san luca on trouve
toujours des rejets pour s'en offusquer
amel bent aurait pris du poids faut
qu'elle se défende je suis chanteuse pas
mannequin ronaldo poste une vidéo de sa
petite famille à vos bonhomme un ballot
pour ton fils un ballet pour ta fille
surtout change rien françaises ou
internationales les stars sont
effectivement devenus nos putching ball
préférées elles ne peuvent plus lever le
petit doigt sans se faire dézinguer sur
les réseaux sociaux en même temps de
temps en temps on a l'impression qu'ils
le font exprès franck ribéry fait ce
qu'il veut de son argent mais avec sa
côte de boeuf en or c'est pas la classe
qui valait tout fait vous l'avez
dézinguer
kim kardashian qui explique à sa fille
pourquoi les paparazzis court après la
voiture
willy
[Musique]
chevillon enflé voulait lui avait cassé
les très amoureux justin bieber et hail
et baldwin poste une échographie
rigolote le 1er avril
il ya tellement de gens qui ne peuvent
pas avoir d'enfant comment osez-vous la
chanteuse pink poste une photo de sa
marmaille à poil
on vous passe les commentaires des
lecteurs quant à nolwenn leroy
elle a le malheur d'allaiter son fils à
à presque deux ans ça va même jusqu'à
laetitia milot lin shi parce qu'elle a
osé changer de coiffure alors traqué en
permanence les stars doivent-elles être
parfaite en toute circonstance et on a
vu à cette semaine encore évidemment
avec les repas lhemanne qu'à parler à
coeur ouvert et derrière toutes les
associations tomber dessus ça a fait une
nouvelle polémique
toutes les polémiques elie semoun sa
part dont moi j'ai envoyé un petit
message de soutien à ce que c'est drôle
ou pas drôle peu importe mais enfin il
fait une blague d'un grand magasin on se
moque de la dé la tête des soi-disant
des pauvres du pack ouais ça devient
hallucinant on a une montre à l'antenne
on a un [ __ ] de riches ont conduit
une voiture
bref je qu'est-ce qui veut ça qu'est ce
qu'il veut ça aujourd'hui est-ce que ça
se justifie donc la question c'était
quoi la question exactement avant les
stars sont l objet d'être parfait
puisque je connais oui et non il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de noms il ya juste un
oui c'est marrant c'est sébastien vous
qu'il est traqué pourquoi oui les stars
sont obligés d'être parfaite
c'est pas qu'ils sont obligés d'être
parfaite mais moi je trouve que en fait
dans la question je trouve que c'est de
leur faute 100% leurs fautes ça existe
est pas ça il ya dix quinze vingt ans
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas les réseaux
sociaux est maintenant il parle à tort
et à travers et souvent de façon
intelligente
donc ils se tuent le monde leur tombe
dessus il s'était beaucoup mieux géré
quand il y avait des professionnels de
la communication pour leur dire quand
est ce qu'ils devaient intervenir dans
tel ou tel média
ouais et que maintenant ils ont
peut-être pas la capacité de communiquer
par brûler les magazines dans gala où il
va l'attaché de presse en avait une
tasse de café la réaliser n'importe quoi
ces coûts ces séries c'était bien mais
c'était contrôlé et là maintenant on se
rend compte que pour une bonne partie
eh ben il se fait donc sa boussole ou de
n'importe quoi un footballeur qui juste
monde dans sa poche pour venir une
marque mais ça me chante ibom dans sa
voiture et ça me choque pas du tout
c'est les bêtises qui raconte ça me
choque pas du tout que j'ai pas de
problème avec l'argent
j'étais quand j'étais aux états unis où
c'était totalement l'effet inverse c'est
à dire qu'une star américaine qui se
montrait avec des belles montres une
belle mêlée
c'était admiré par le reste de la
population c'est en france qu'on a ce
problème là non moi je parlais de la
communication à tort et à travers des
gens à travers les réseaux d'accord
alors est la triste mort ne serait pas
le problème comme ça sébastien il ya des
magazines qui font ça qu'ils soient
people qui soit être intrusive d'allier
privée des gens c'est pas ça le problème
le problème ce sont les réseaux sociaux
en eux mêmes les régions c'est quoi
c'est des gens qui donnent leur avis
alors avant ça sortait pas du bistrot du
village et bistroquet et maintenant
c'est n'importe qui n'importe quoi quand
on voit la violence la délation c'est
n'importe quoi
moi je n'ai que je déteste dans les eaux
sage est pas satisfait pas le citer mais
je trouve que c'est c'est ça le problème
c'est que ce système est sûre palmade
son palmarès et pas n'importe qui font
des associations gays très sérieuse qui
ont lancé ça sur les réseaux et la
violence elle vient à 90 % de gens qui
disent des méchants ce n'est qu'ils
disent n'est pas nommé ça sert et
sociaux mais mais ce côté
par exemple ces fausses preuves bah
voilà nolwenn leroy qui allait de sa
salle son enfant pendant 21 mois
on a envie de dire aux gens elle fait ce
qu'elle veut le fonds gama
elle se fait insulter l'autre ibérique
qui bouffe ça ça sur notre côte avec de
l'or dessus il est parti de rien il a
réussi là fait une belle carrière
pourquoi est-ce qui éventuellement on
admire pas plus tôt mais le crash elle
avait droit mais c'est sa fin dans sept
ans
c'est parfait ah oui mais qu'est ce
qu'un problème ça mathieu s'est paré
malgré l'émotion l'a remporté sur la rue
c'est tout le problème de palmade c'est
un bon exemple cirque les gens ont réagi
sur l'émotion pure d'une manière
complètement hystérique
alors qu'il faisait une chose vous êtes
très bien défendu vous avez vu dans
l'émission il a dit c'est son avis il a
le droit de la voix en plus ou à
soutient guy legay qu'il veut est
exactement
et aujourd'hui alors tout le monde veut
rentrer dans l'intimité d'autres et
réagir sur voilà une manière pour les
profanes rappeler une chose c'est une
minorité qui fait du bruit
la majorité silencieuse et heureusement
et bienveillante c'est simplement les
gens qui ne rient 13 ans elle est très
dense elle est dans la lumière de cette
minorité pardon c'est pâques et les
réseaux sociaux ça s'enflamme lova ça
dans les joueurs allaient y aller pardon
mais il ya les sites internet dédiés les
joues calé public.fr on a parlé
malheureusement les sites internet c'est
pas forcément la même chose que ce qui
assure le magazine
dans l'écrit souvent il ya là dans la
merde
c'est quoi ça reste factuel ils sont pas
là en train de faire j'ai pas longtemps
j'ai dû sur plaza dans l'émission tpm pg
10 ya trop d'immobilier à l'antenne
public.fr matthieu delormeau linge
stéphane raynal en tête on a cru qu'il
allait me laisser voler pour m'insulter
on a déjà eu cette envie de mourir et
puis je sais me répondre alors ben ali
partent pas tous en même temps on peut
pas voir une star exemplaire sinon ce ne
serait pas une star une star c'était une
star parce qu'elle fait parler vous
rebondissez sur chaque chose que la star
fait si une star et lycées qu'elle n'a
rien à dire tu n as rien à faire elle en
serait pas son statut de son père qui
avait pas les journalistes pour parler
des stars y aurait dès lors que tu
parles journalistes de toi un
journaliste de moi c'est vraiment une
carte de presse pour une carte d'après
néo tient non mais sinon
bah c'est pas une 4 vers les mobiles
sont chacun au final pas donné plus
d'importance aux choses aussi qu'elles
n'en ont coiffé de faire tout un tas de
déchets mais c'est tout le temps en
enfance et va tout va bien c'est pas
grave le monde est beau et c'est bah oui
parce que voilà les l'iris l'arrêt -
analyse du mal de moi dans mon dos mon
cul les contemple c'est ça qui devrait
répondre exactement aux magazines et
c'est west d'accord à verser les
sondages entre a pas mieux
c'est alors voilà faut-il être
irréprochable quand on est une star
bah oui non 52% à ce gentil bah voilà
bon mon cher non mais moi je le trouve
un petit peu le même exemple vous prenez
une boîte but dans paris par exemple eh
bien vous n'êtes pas connu vous avez un
pv vous êtes connus et bien gras
toujours quelqu'un dans un magazine
comme publique qui durera arrêté dans
une boîte bus macha nana miracle pour
qu'ils finissent tard il prend la voie
des bus ben comme beaucoup de gens j'ai
fait des conneries pas pour moi de
passer le parisien il dit machin il a
été acheté ces costumes is les faits ils
les achètent pas est l'effet offrir
c'est exactement la date moi quand tu bu
un verre de trop que tu fais une
connerie on n'en est même pas quelque
part on marque pages et pour ma part
parce que ça c'est l'aigreur au son